um
we have only one apology and it's from
his worship somebody like to move that
that's accepted
counselor abbott council of sopa open
for discussion
there is none i'll put the vote all in
favor
against carried
which brings us to uh
public forum i've got an update from
south alive
not coming excellent that shortened the
meeting
brings us to the youth council ladies
would like to come up and take a seat
welcome along
if you'd like to introduce yourself to
counsellors and take us through your
report
and uh share with us your video
um well hello i'm katiana simpson and
i'm from
the youth council hi i'm libby and i'm
from new council
um so to begin with um we're one of our
youth councillors who went to activate
which is a week in camp with other youth
council members
from all around new zealand and it's in
christchurch and it focuses on youth
development
and governance training we also had
michael morris attended youth council
youth council meeting and he spoke to us
about representation review and voting
systems such as first pastor posts
and stv um it was really interesting for
us as like
people who are going into learning how
to vote and things like that and hear
the different viewpoints and the
possibility of a maori ward
the youth council also helped promote
the ltp engagement
within our peers and in our schools and
things and it was really interesting
also to see
an insight on the statistics of how the
community voted on the three major
projects
um we've also been offered the
opportunity for youth council
representatives to sit on the maori repo
which is a group of staff set up to
develop and encourage maori culture at
the council
and councillor crackit will be attending
the festival of the future with two of
our
cheer persons in wellington in july
um also at the moment one of our
subcommittees the leadership committee
is working on
organizing a event with the united
nations youth
re youth group and
it's a regional hui um this will be held
on saturday the 19th of june um at the
federated farms building
um this
event is following the youth decoration
event that was held in wellington
recently
and young people from all over
southland and from years 9 to 13
and high schools have been informed
about this will
be available to come to this event and
learn about leadership and national
problems
that they will be given an opportunity
to
help create a solution um also
the youth wheat committee has kindly
donated
the clip and climb prizes that they were
given
for the youth week project that didn't
um end up happening so
these will be handed out at this
regional huey
also the youth council are planning on
putting a facebook post
in support of pride month and
have strongly shown their support for
lgbtqia
ideas and initiatives so watch the space
we also have youth council members
working in collaboration with
creative and active committee
funding communities funding committees
and we also have volunteers teams at
working with the library
on some new projects um
also before our youth council meetings
start but before we start our combined
meetings
we like to join together and send the
council whiter and we've got actually
got a recording that we've got for you
to listen to today
thank you councillors any questions
councillor sopa thank you um if one of
us was interested in
dropping into the united nations
training would that be okay and if that
is okay what time does it start
um yeah that's that would be really cool
um
it starts at 9 a.m and ends at 3 00 p.m
on saturday the 19th great thank you
thank you any other questions
getting off lightly well done uh
counselors on move that the report
is uh received is there a second thing
councillor lewis
i'll put that all in favor against
carried thank you for exiting school
early
to be here sacrificing your education in
such a way
thanks very much we appreciate your work
with us
council as we move to the minutes of the
extraordinary meeting of performance
policy and partnerships
on may the 11th if somebody wants to
move their true and correct record
moved councillor abbott councillor sopa
any points from that anybody's wishing
to discuss
if not i'll put the motion all in favor
aye against
kerry uh ppp meeting
part two uh the three o'clock
session councillor abbott again and
council of sloper again
new points from that meeting
put the motion then all in favor aye aye
against
carried and that brings us to the
extraordinary meeting
on may 18th council amundsen
and council skilled yep
says i wasn't there but i was there i
managed to move a motion
congratulations if we can
uh amend the minutes to record
councillor rabbit's
movement mover and second to happy with
that
cool thanks put the motion then all in
favor
aye against carried
uh brings us to the uh proposed
right of way from the subdivision at 266
bay road
michael oh you're going to give us a
tune
hi councillors i'll take the report as
read and available for any questions
relatively straightforward there's two
recommendations
i'm happy to move move council emanson
seconded
cancel a kit open for comment
if there is none i'll put the motion all
in favor
against carried
statement of intent from the bluff
maritime museum trust
again just two pretty straightforward
recommendations michael
um yes hello councillors i just like
draw your attention to
the item two of the recommendations
which is just asking for
some further supporting information in
relation to the
investments that are held by the museum
just understand what their future
intention is
in relation to this
but no material change to the statement
of intent that is correct counseling
thanks
councillor sopa happy to move that way
mr chair
thank you seconded by councillors
pottinger
no comments if not i put the motion all
in favor
against carried
casey
we've got the uh hearings for the um
proposed hearings for the draft
environmental reserves omnibus
it's a great word there's a few of them
um
i'll take the reporter's read and
welcome any questions or comments
so in the recommendations we're looking
for
three counsellors that proposes that i'm
one of them but we need another two to
be
on the hearing committee are there any
volunteers
i'm not volunteering i'm just asking a
question oh
you were almost almost on the panel
the question is regarding you know
hearing experience you know obviously
some of the counselors here have
um hearing experience with training and
stuff
um this isn't an rma hearing and really
no different to the process that we go
through
for say the long-term plans okay no
that's fine let's answer my question
any volunteers before i pick two
councillor clark lack of anyone else and
councillor lewis
thank you so that would be
nominating three councillors um included
so we're naming councillor clark and
councillor lewis in there somebody want
to move those three recommendations i'll
move that
thank you second thank you
questions or comments there are none
i'll put that all in favor
against carried thanks cassie
fees and charges
welcome up brianna michael's on standby
thank you check your counselors i'll
just take the report as
read so essentially a lot of what we're
going through for the
the next few motions we've received
as draft reports um gone through the ltp
consultation process and some amendments
made there are some changes
that i'll get you to highlight as we
come to each each of those papers but
for fees and charge it charges it's as
noted with the full recommendations
i'll move that thanks counselor partner
secondly counselor sopa
no questions or comments counselor clark
yeah sorry for likeness
um in the submissions i noticed that
rodney tribe raids is an
interesting issue about the uh the
surplus that we're running in
under the dog control act so i just
wanted some clarification about
um whether that's an ongoing
thing and whether we potentially are
charging too much i know there's a
comparison with other councils
um and secondly if we do run any
services out of this
portion of our revenue whether we can
use it
for other functions as opposed to being
just ring fence for
the animal control area if it's rated
for animal control it would need to be
used for animal control
my understanding michael
so i can't thank you through yourself
the chair
um just that to answer that i've got to
put that into two parts
so not the full uh surplus from that
perspective
is related to the dog fees from that
perspective there's more
to the charges than that staff time etc
associated to that where there's been
underspin on expenditure
in relation to anything that goes from
the
dog fees into the reserves it does need
to be used for the
uh dog related activities from that
perspective
so we do have some reserves that go
through to that
it does all doesn't it does it does okay
can can i ask him following on from
there
is it um an option for us to use
any of that surplus for education of
responsibilities
for dog owners and animal control
it's for er yes sorry sir too it's
through any activity in relation to dogs
so as long as it's about the dog control
component from that perspective yes that
is one aspect that can be useful
thank you councillor partner um
going back to 2000 and it was late 10 or
2011
uh the funds the the accrued funds were
actually used to build the new pound
we were it was used to be a dirty
concrete bunker behind the
wastewater ponds and
after much debate it seems sensible to
use the crude money to do that
but moving forward as the current
infrastructure
are we putting aside money through
different infrastructure funds for the
building
or is this money because i know it was
used then for infrastructure
um do we do we funded
you know repairs and maintenance on the
building separately or
how do we do that through yourself chair
uh
yes this fund will be used in relation
to doing some of the works in relation
to the
the dog pound itself so there are some
within that long-term plan that we're in
relation to the
um dog pound area and yes those funds
will be utilized
right so they will they you know they
may not be used now but they will be
used so
the other thing is asking about michael
this is not question for you is
the capacity of the dog pound are we is
it is it working
to its size or are we finding that the
request for accommodation is
is is too big for the rooms or
steve thank you through cheer um
thank you councillor look the team have
undertaken a review
of the current services around the dog
pound and there are additional works
underway right now including increasing
the exercise
area around the side we're reviewing our
delivery
against the i guess the relevant code
there is capacity there now
however at certain times a year we do
get close to hitting that capacity but
we haven't had any issues yet
right okay that's fine thank you
thanks for that any further questions or
around fees and charges
if there are none that's been moved and
seconded i'll put the motion all in
favor
against carried the
next item is the adoption of liability
management policy
uh again any changes in here from the
draft
um so again um
this is relating to the long-term plan
this is one of the policies linked to
the long-term plan
um we're not proposing significant
any significant changes as a result of
consultation
so through recommendations if there's a
mover i'll move
councillor evert seconded
councillor amundsen councillor partner
um look i've just got a question and uh
it's regarding
um our a plus rating and where it
applies
because i know there's quite a few
policies coming up and and it's
it is mentioned later on but
with the objectives of this particular
policy it looks at
um minimizing borrowing costs and things
like that now
i'm just trying to get my head around
our borrowing costs are reflective of
our rating does that is that right
and is that is that one of the things i
just didn't see it in here i was
trying to work out how it all fits
together
michael can you help with that one
through yourself chair uh
this is one of the combination of
policies that go towards
the rating from that perspective you
have the investment uh policy as well as
your
revenue and financing financial strategy
and rating policy as well
that all combine in relation to that
rating they look at a whole lot in the
financial prudence of council at the
time so
it's a combination from that respect
it's just one of many
okay so my next question is then really
how much it is in our control uh
to to keep this and how much is out of
our control just the way things happen
so cheer a little difficult to say uh
quite a lot is within the control of
council and in the policy settings and
how we manage our finances
ongoing um it's quite clear at the
moment from a prudence point of view
we're getting the double a plus rating
um we got it this time there's no reason
to see we're not on
from my perspective on negative watch so
all things being held with the policy
staying pretty much the same and our
financials the same should stay pretty
stable
but having said that there are external
aspects that do come into it that are
outside council's control
that we cannot play part in that's a
worldwide or
even a national now thanks for that that
shows that all those policies combined
to do that thanks for that thanks for
the question
so it's moved councillor abbott seconded
councillor amundsen for no further
questions i'll put the motion all in
favor
against carried second spoke on that
wheel is the adoption of
investment policy and again this is
pretty much what we've gone out to
consult with through the ltp process
mover and second deleted counselor sopa
and councillor lewis any questions
counselor clark yeah thank you on page
136
of their books um
it talks um about the feedback we got
from submissions and also some officer's
advice and i was interested in about the
fourth of her paragraph
down that said rather than council
investing directly in commercial
activities the role of ichl which is
holco
is to be considered and that raises the
issue that i've raised before about why
we have commercial activities like
the aru farm and the don street property
sitting within council's books when
ideally they should be over
under holco where we have a basically a
an invocable city properties company
which basically has no properties within
it
and so um i guess is the wider question
that i actually agree with the
submissions that have been made
a little bit further up around the
investment and the sale of
investment and that's reflected again in
the um
on page 139 the first bullet point on
that when it talks about objectives to
me is
too vague and it's wording it leaves the
door open that we could continue to
invest in
properties like our farm and like don
street
and keep them away from our holding
company which is where the
investment property should be the
negativity of holding them internally is
i struggle to get a straight answer on
um how those properties are going
especially the dawn street one
um where if they were sitting in a hole
co in the property company
it would be very transparent through uh
six months being an annual
uh reporting about how those investments
were going and tracking
so there's a quite a wide issue for me
about around
where we hold our investments and and
why we hold them internally
thanks for the comment wasn't a question
was it counsellor well i i i i
guess i was just really reinforcing that
for me the wording of that
of that investment policy on page 139 is
too vague in the first bullet point
thank you knows it
councillor lewis yeah the property
company under holco i don't think has
any directors in it anyway it's sort of
like a shell companies
at the stage i may be an error there
mrs hadley uh mr chair uh councillor
lewis is correct that that was the case
at one stage but it does indeed
have directors again at this point in
time
no further questions or comments
okay it's been moved in second and i'll
put the motion all in favor
aye aye against care carried and noted
councillor clark you
like your vote recorded thank you thank
you the adoption of significance and
engagement policy
i'll move that way mr chief thanks
councillor cyprus secretary councillor
amundson
any points you want to highlight serena
i need to know that this policy is
really important policy for council in
terms of it directs
how we will consult and engage and we've
worked closely
with manufa on the section that relates
to engagement with maori
thank you for that so no further
comments i'll put the motion all in
favor
against carried
confirmation of the revenue and finance
policy
any changes that need to be noted in
here rihanna
not to this one no
thank you and then there would note the
uh the appendix
appendices somebody like to move the
three recommendations counselor scout
counselor partner
questions or comments clark
on page 175 i see uh uh
jeanette pickford raised the issue which
has been raised before with us
about um the living wage and i just
wonder where council's out with
with the living wage are we heading
towards adopting that or is it still
something that we are not not going to
be bound by
operational matter really i think but
morally clear do you want to
respond uh mr chair i think the response
to the submitter was given in the
um material that came back to council at
the time that you were looking
at deliberations
where are we sorry late in may
and the explanation was given there that
uh we have adopted a point between the
national minimum wage
and the living wage a mechanism we've
called the icc fair wage
really going for it today
good thing it was at that end of the cup
thank you any further questions
if there are none i'll put the motion
all in favor
against carrie confirmation of
rating policy again looking for a mover
and a second
i'll move that way and councillor scout
thank you
brianna um again so this this is one of
the financial policies that aligns with
the revenue and finance policy
there's no change to the policy itself
but i'll just note
that during the audit process when
we picked up there is actually going to
be slight changes to
the cover report so on page
195 table under 4.784
um the comparative um amounts
for the rates increases are slightly
different this does not affect the
rating policy itself
um but it's this is an example table
that helps people
look on average what will the rates
increases be
and that final table will be included
within the long term
plan itself which you'll receive on the
30th of june
so no change to the rating policy but
just to note that that table there
will be updated thanks rhiannon
it's been moved and seconded are there
any further questions
if not i'll put the motion all in favor
against
carried the adoption of the remission
and postponements of rates on maori
freehold land
i'll move that way mr chair thank you
seconder
councillor pardon jamboree anything to
note from
changes from the draft so just um draw
your attention to the fact that there's
a legislative change coming from
central government which um we weren't
aware of at the time of
consultation so it does require a change
to our policy
but the report outlines the fact that
there is no
substantive change as a result of
the policy change because in practice
the way we are rating the small number
of
relevant properties within the
invercargill area already aligns with
the new
regulation being set by central
government so this report just outlines
all of that detail
and includes the new policy for adoption
no further consultations recommended
thank you
it's been moved and seconded put the
motion all in favor
aye against carrie thank you for that
uh draft development contributions
policy
i'll move that one second
second council of soper thank you
rhiannon
a short policy this one but again one of
the financial policies
and consultation has been completed
thank you
there are no questions or comments
i put the motion all in favor against
carried brings us to the confirmation of
the financial strategy and
infrastructure strategy
so um for this um report i'll just note
the updates that you received to board
books
over the um on friday as a result of
feedback
from the auditors they are very small
changes
but i will just alert you to that so it
relates to the assumptions so the
assumptions are listed separately
in um recommendation five but they are
also included in the infrastructure
strategy which is why both of those
documents were updated so the audit has
picked up an
error that we had not updated completely
the assumption around the delivery of
the capital works program so that is now
been corrected and then i received one
further one today which we will make but
you've not yet received so that's just
to note that again in the assumptions
this is relating to the assumption
around three waters reform
they've requested the change of one word
from well to may
in terms of this will happen or this may
happen
so the assumption will now read that
three waters reform
means that the service of water may be
provided by another provider
so that's a just a small wording change
within the assumptions document
thank you noting that change there are
five recommendations council of soap is
moving
and seconded by councillor partner
councillor soper
just before you want to pull that mike
in just before the vote
i notice on page 229
um that there's another instance where
it is possible we might want to change
will to may
that's under the major demographic
shocks the first bullet point
and i'm suggesting that because all the
current reporting is that
that is much more likely to be a may
than a will
you spotted where that's it michael do
you want to comment
yes happy to have that amendment made
thank you so
over and second are comfortable with
that yeah yeah yep thank you
councillor partner um i'd like to speak
to
appendix 2 and that's the infrastructure
strategy
and how it applies to section 101b of
the local government act
and that 101b is that the local
authority must
was part of his long-term plan prepare
and adopt a 30-year consecutive
financial year
infrastructure strategy now that that's
good and
and i totally agree with it and that's
probably
why our infrastructure and invercargill
is is good
but um recently i was in wanaka
for one of the three water forums and i
asked the question
to those who were who were leading the
forum about
what will happen to our 30-year
infrastructure strategy
and the answer wasn't that reassuring in
the fact that
they said uh well that goes and
they basically there is no strategy
as we know it and i'm just it i'm just
raising this point and it's something to
look at
maybe they will incorporate that in the
new entities that they have to
enact section 101b but at that
particular time
um i was very weary that
a move to a new entity may not give us
um the the guarantees that we need but
that's something that we will look into
obviously when we make a decision
but just on face value now
the answer wasn't the one i really was
hoping for
because you know infrastructure like
this is 30 years it makes sense
that you put it out there
rather than moving to a reactionary
regime
and that's not what you want so your
point is that we put in a 30-year
infrastructure plan that they don't feel
obliged to follow if there's a change of
ownership
that's right we don't know where that
sits will we still have a 30-year plan
that identifies
where our old pipes are where everything
is and that keeps us going as it has for
the
last 30 years the 30 years before that
so
yeah i just thought i'd raise that point
it's one of those things for the
infrastructure
strategy we have now but um
we can talk about it when we discuss
tree waters
thanks councillor thanks for drawing our
attention to that
any other questions or comments
counselor claim yeah in relation to the
sale of don street which is one of the
recommendations here i don't support
that
and so i'd like some clarification on
the information that's
on the last paragraph of page 220
where it refers to the property having a
value of 14.5 million
and it says that we make a net surplus
of
600 000 a year but i need to know
whether the net surplus
includes the debt that's currently
sitting on don street
or whether it includes the debt that was
created by remortgaging
lower s street which occurred
a couple of years ago and where the
re-mortgaging
of that money went into don street
that's my understanding so we have a
current debt on don street uh sorry
lower street
2.35 million dollars i understand
and that money was used into dollar
street so i want to make sure that the
figures that are in front of us today
when it says that we can continue to
service
includes the debt on their lower east
street properties
as well so that's that's the first point
on the second point is
14.5 million if we sold that building
even though we still
service the debt overall in our
borrowings or debt levels
uh does free up an awful lot of money
that could be used elsewhere in the ltp
michael do you want to handle part one
or part two as well if you wish uh thank
you
through yourself the chair i can
probably handle all of the parts
uh look from a investment point of view
in relation to don street uh
given the interest rates are so low at
the moment is probably the blessing that
gives it
to that balance where it is now in a net
positive
point of view from perspective of
revenue over um current costs
so it makes makes sense from that point
of view that
it stays on as an investment until such
time as that
becomes the opposite way around and that
could be a change of a couple of points
in relation to your interest rates from
that perspective but at this point if
you were to
remove it from your financial planning
from that perspective it would have a
negative impact in relation to that
and put a higher burden back onto the
rates
so at the moment it's positively
contributing
in relation to yes the full net debt uh
from the other side
if you took it out it would have a
negative impact in relation to that
that's not to say that that would change
you know with the movement of interest
rates that would
most certainly um have an impact on that
decision as time goes by
so just let me clarify that because i'm
not clear i've got the answer i was
looking for
i understand that all up the amount of
funding we put into dawn street runs
somewhere north of 18 million
and i understand also this predates this
term
that we also took some money via
endowment funding
out of lower s street when we refinance
the buildings that are there
which are basically derelict and the
money transferred across to don street
as part of the
capital investment there so what i'm
seeking is when you say that we've got a
cash flow positive situation
is that addressing the money that was
transferred from
lower don street across because that's
still got to be paid
chair i can come back to council in
relation to the impact of that
all i can look at is from current
position and whether it's a positive or
a negative
impact on online so yes i can have a
look at that come back to councilman
my understanding is if there was a
portion of funding that came across to
don street from endowment funds that
would need to go back to endowment funds
but we'll get that answer back to you
thanks councillor clark
any further questions if not we have a
move from the second or i'll put the
motion
all in favor aye against
noting councillor clark's vote against
thank you
uh submission to the environment
southland long
term plan
so this report is for information um
includes the submission that was made um
on behalf of council to environment
south and foreign conversations
with the chairs as a result of the
communication that environment south and
sent
to council and you all received a few
weeks ago when their consultation
commenced so outlines
a number of issues for their
consideration
thanks raynon councillors our two
recommendations need to move from the
secondary council of sopa
and councillor abbott it's there for
comments
councillor partner well the one that
stands out to me is the
notified resource consent initial
deposits and hearing fee
now as i actually had to
sort of put on two sets of glasses to
see it was correct and it is
um so is this a i mean is this
justifiable
in their reasoning for this
um to cover recover costs because
these fees i think should you know
reflect cost recovery but is the
justification
that yes it would be around cost
recovery
and firstly and secondly that experience
shows that a lot of the costs are higher
than the initial deposit paid which
comes at quite some surprise to the
applicant
so in effect esr striving to be
more transparent about the likely final
cost
and they will return that notice
the use of the word deposit but
uh on your behalf i'd be happy to
clarify that with them
so claire is going along and speaking to
our submission i see that yeah thank you
thank you councillor sopa thanks mr
chair i had also noted that particular
one
and was very happy that we had um
that we had included it in our
submission because i think we would
all like to have that one clarified
re-looked it it does seem on the face of
it our wording is quite
it does seem hard to justify
there may be an answer we'll see how the
submission goes
do we have some notified consents coming
up i just wondered
the answer to that as we usually do
okay it's been moved and seconded i'll
put the motion all in favor
against carrie thanks for that
that brings us to the activity report
uh and again some you know really
pleasing figures in there
steve is there anything you uh you want
to highlight for councillors
thank you mr chairman good afternoon
councillors uh
look i'll take the report as read and
wearing two hats of the customer and
environment group
group manager as well as the leisure and
wreck so
yeah happy to take any questions we'll
note i think
overall pleasing performance on page one
from the planning and building team
uh really good result there we've also
seen the impact on the vaccination
clinic
and the numbers in the civic theatre and
we've made a note though that
this isn't a long-term
solution we should see that that number
might pop back down once the clinic is
finished
but also pleasingly the numbers in
hawakituya
are starting to respond now to us
putting more exhibitions
and events on and we are starting to see
greater community engagement
how long is the cover clinic expected to
continue in the victoria rooms
uh it was approximately 12 months
commencing last
month so i think this time next year
based on current rollout again the
ministry of health will
ultimately determine when that finishes
thank you councillors any questions or
comments around the activity report
councillor sopa thanks mr chair i just
wanted through steve to pass on
compliments to the invercargill public
library they seem to be
doing some very exciting things at the
moment
um just digitising the nakamai herald
um in collaboration is is a great
achievement and will add to i think
what needs to be acknowledged as some
very fine
archives we've got stored there and some
of the program initiatives so
just worthy of a thank you i think from
councillors
well you can see the level of engagement
i saw a couple of the library staff
out walking through the cbd with a group
of students and it's
you know again activities that are not
the usual but
get people along and using the facility
that might not otherwise have been in
there
there's great engagement with youth and
and
increasing diversity around adult
engagement too so that's really
very pleasing if there any other
questions or comments counselors
looking for a mover that the reports
received counselors open counselor scout
thank you
i'll put the motion then all in favor
aye
against carried
that brings us to the quarterly
financials
okay and jamie
the floor is yours um i'll take the
report as read but i wanted to highlight
a couple of points
mainly the overall performance of the
council for this is to the nine months
to march
we are performing better than what we
had planned
to be however there's still three
well at this point there was still three
months to go we're in the last month
and as our friends further north have
found out
things can happen in the last month of
the financial year that you don't always
plan for
but at the moment we are tracking um
pretty much to that plan
again this comment in the report about
our inability to give you exactly what
you have previously given
been given in a quarterly report and we
are continuing to work we've made some
advances and this paper's coming to risk
and assurance
run up that coming to risk and assurance
um
other than that the treasury one
when we go to the treasury you'll see if
you've delved right through your pack
that there is the potential for us to be
breaching some of our limits
um that and the
liability management policy and treasury
policies that you've just
considered we have changed those limits
slightly
with on advice from our advisors
treasury advisors
that will take that potential breach
away from one
july um it's literally about
how much we hedge at the moment and
given that the interest rates are
staying low
there's no need to do a lot of forward
hedging
that is comforting
um other than that is there any other
questions
thanks councillors
councillor clark um just in relation to
uh
our overall debt i noticed on page 304
it says that we've got 95 million
dollars worth of uh
of debt core debt being 95 43 being on
lent to
the holding company so
an overall figure of 138 and when i
recently
read the three waters um data that's
been given to us and based on what rangi
was saying before
i get some very conflicting information
about what our true level of debt is
and what our true level of borrowings
are against ill
gfa criteria and so i see in the in the
um
in the three waters space that we get
quite a bit of
stuff saying that if we continue to opt
out and provide services ourselves
we'll breach that 300 limit and yet when
i look at figures like this
um that sort of creates a lower figure
than what we've actually got
so i'm a bit confused about that i don't
normally have that with the
financial stuff
so you might be able to help me with
that michael
want to have a shot through yourself the
chair
um need to take into account when you're
looking at
the debt side of it this is total debt
not net debt so
just take that into account in relation
to looking at numbers in relation to the
three waters reporting etc but i
wouldn't want to bring the three
water reporting through and the numbers
into this meeting at this stage because
i'm still conducting my review of the
information that's in there
they've analyzed what we provided them
and provided something back that we
haven't yet reviewed so
i'd like to do that first uh in relation
to
our debt cap slow from that perspective
they are
they are consistent with what we've got
and going forward into the
long term plan the only caveat would be
the repayment in relation to the
holdings money that has been transferred
back that we've
had approval to pay pay off which will
has happened in this quarter so that
will be reflected in the
final report so our total debt will be
lower than what this
report has currently got on it
councillor clark yeah just one other
issue which runs on page 328
it talks about our current borrowings
and it seems that we're running out
about uh about 130 million
in borrowing um so given that the
local government funding agency allows a
cap of 300
so that based on our current revenue
would be 300 million
we're conservatively very low are we in
our borrowings
am i right to consume that and we've
seen that
yourself cheer yes that is correct um
council set it at a 150 percent which is
quite considerably
lower than the uh available and just one
final clarification just around the
issue of the holding co
at the moment do we factor in the
holding code when we're looking at
borrowing
and if the answer is yes to that is
there some potential that at some later
stage
in the not too distant future we will
not have to take that into account that
they will stand alone
for yourself chair uh the holding
company is only taken into account
at the moment due to the uh and the loan
and investment that occur in relation to
the forward borrowing that we have
um the repayment that we've just made
will
take that out of the picture so from my
uh from perspective going forward
the holding company is taken into
account from a council perspective when
setting
the 150 uh threshold um
being very prudent in relation to having
the
uncalled capital from an lgfa they do
not take that into account
in relation to their debt cap so we're
able to borrow it
from their perspective at a higher level
thank you thanks for the question
there any further questions or comments
did i get them over my apologies move
councillor clark second councillor soper
the three recommendations i'll put those
all in favor
aye against
carrie thank you for that
uh last item in public is
the report from claire around the
lgnz agm
there's a recommendation or two
recommendations there it's a mover
councillor kit seconder councillor lewis
looking for comment no question
councillor bartinger um look just a
timing thing when do these
remits normally come to us to have a bit
of a
yeah funny you should ask that the ce
and i were having a very discussion just
beforehand
uh mr shearer i would say in the next
couple of weeks
right so it comes through here again yes
so um
at the moment i thought we could
probably end up dealing with the remits
to get direction
at our extraordinary meeting is it an
extraordinary meeting
on june 30th cool which is you know
adopting the ltp
yeah it's relatively straightforward it
gives us two weeks yeah yep
councillor clark and so as a lead on to
that it's probably good that we have
yourself and uh councillor crackit uh
nominated for this because and it's not
just a matter of remits because
sometimes remembers can be amended on
the floor can't they
yes so it's a matter of keeping up with
the debates as they go along
correct thank you it's been moved and
seconded
put the motion all in favor against
carried councillors thank you that
brings us to the end of the
public part of the meeting i'll move
that we go into public excluded for the
reasons as outlined in the agenda
with the exception of mr grant and mr
mckenzie
remain as external appointees mr hardy
and mr hardy mr hardy as well thank you
you could
we trust you implicitly so is
you